[Applause]
and I wanted to say the Robert Spencer
is a very special person
he created jihad watch which is part of
our arsenal to defend our civilization
against its enemies without and within
who are very numerous I want to thank
Joyce Chernykh for bringing Robert to us
and for supporting him well he's part of
our universe the reason you don't see a
lot of Robert is he lives in the on the
East Coast so this is a special day
Robert is special in two two ways first
of all is one of the most courageous
individuals on the right just because we
at the center I've taken on the
Islamists and have been doing it for 15
20 years all of us are hated yeah you've
I don't know if you've watched all these
black lists going up all over the place
but we're all hated but none of us are
hate it as much as Robert and the reason
is as you said those of you who have
seen him know he's a very mild-mannered
person the reason that he's hated is
because he's so knowledgeable he he has
invested so much energy he's written I
don't know if it's a dozen books now all
of them really indispensable and there
are copies out there and that's why
we're holding this event for his new one
but he's put the intellectual energy
it's easy to just be discouraged by the
lying of the left I mean that for an
intellectual it's very dispiriting to
engage well with the Islamists but with
the so-called liberals they lie all the
time
they don't deal with when you refute
their lives they call you names and
attack you so just as as somebody who
does what Robert does I can tell you to
have support like this is really
important but it takes an inner
fortitude to do what Robert has done I
want to thank him for doing that I am
very grateful for all your kind words
and yes you know the flagship
publication of the David Horowitz
freedom centers front page magazine and
if you go to front page magazine on the
masthead it says inside every liberal is
a totalitarian screaming to get out and
they're getting out now it's happening
we have seen especially after the
incident in Charlottesville which
apparently was a neo-nazi psychopath who
drove his car into a crowd of leftists I
say apparently not because I subscribe
to any wild conspiracy theories or
anything of that kind but there are a
lot of questionable aspects to that
whole incident one of the most notable
ones being that the organizer of the
alt-right
or neo-nazi or white supremacist or
whatever it was demonstration was a
member of Occupy the Occupy movement and
an Obama organizer just last year and so
you got a wonder did he undergo such a
rapid conversion to this suppose it
far-right and become its leader in such
a short time or is there more to this
than meets the eye
but in any case whatever happened there
the left has been using the incident at
Charlottesville to try to once again
overreach and make sure that no
dissenting view can be enunciated that
absolutely nothing except the far left
agenda can be spoken in the public
square
and after Charlottesville they have been
using it using the incident to move in
for the kill and one of the chief
weapons that they have been using in
doing this is of course the notorious
hate group list of the Southern Poverty
Law Center and the Southern Poverty Law
Center as many of you know started out
in the 70s I was one of its early donors
and I wish I could get that money back
but anyway it was fighting the Klan and
neo-nazis and
who could who could object but of course
the Klan and the Nazis in real life
aside from what you might read in the
New York Times are here on CNN in real
life
the Klan and neo-nazis are negligent
forces negligible forces I should say
excuse me that don't have any
significant power and are not menacing
people on a large scale in the United
States today this is not to excuse them
it's just to recognize that there's a
great deal of hysteria surrounding them
today in large part because of the
Southern Poverty Law Center by the end
of the 70s the Southern Poverty Law
Center was victorious it had fought the
Klan in several lawsuits it had won and
the Klan was a spent force so what it
should have done was go out of business
vote itself out of existence at that
time but of course as we know
organizations don't do that they just
find other things to reap refocus upon
and the SPLC decided to become
essentially an attack dog for the left
by lumping in perfectly legitimate
organizations with real hate groups and
thereby try to tar marginalize and
ultimately destroy groups that were
perfectly legitimate but which
enunciated a point of view that the
Southern Poverty Law Center opposed and
it's a really very very clever tactic
diabolically clever but undeniably
clever and we saw how it worked right
after Charlotte's ville and when CNN
published their list 917 hate groups in
the United States and only in the small
print did it initiative
the initial CNN reports say this is
according to the Southern Poverty Law
Center nowhere did CNN explain that the
Southern Poverty Law Center does not
include any groups that are not on the
right any groups on the Left as hate
groups you cannot be a hate group and be
on the left as far as the SPLC is
concerned
nowhere did they explain why the SPLC is
a neutral arbiter of what constitutes a
hate group at all or what qualifies them
to tell us what is a hate group and what
isn't nowhere was this explained all it
said was here are the hate groups in
your area and it was really quite a
remarkable thing to scroll through this
list I don't know if any of you saw it
but it made even though I was appalled
and disgusted because of course there
was jihad watch and the David Horowitz
Freedom Center and other perfectly
legitimate groups many of which I
personally involved in as well there
were also they were right next to these
groups like the skinheads for white
supremacy and the neo-nazis for Aryan
descendants and so you're reading along
and it's it's just absolutely weird and
I made me wonder can anybody really be
taking this seriously that it says
bloodthirsty Aryans for death David
Horowitz freedom Center how can you
possibly think this is a real list but
they do and not only that it's been an
annoyance for years that we have been
listed as hate groups by the Southern
Poverty Law Center but after Charlotte's
fell it's much more than an annoyance it
has been used to attempt to deny as a
platform entirely and you need to know
that there are very very concerted
efforts now to cut off the so called
hate groups from any access to the
primary means of communication and most
notably all of the things that give you
a significant platform on the internet
recently this fellow wrote me somebody
I'd never known and he said then he sent
me a notice that he'd gotten from
YouTube and the YouTube notice said you
or playlist' has been barred has been
blocked from YouTube as inappropriate
and you know what the title of the
playlist was Robert Spencer my videos
are still on YouTube on my channel I
think that they targeted this guy
because he told me in his email that he
just he'd actually forgotten he had this
and he had just set aside a few of my
videos because he wanted to watch them
later and I think they went after him
and not after my own jihad watch Channel
on YouTube because they knew that if
they went after me directly there would
be an outcry but they could get rid of
his and nobody would particularly notice
because he's not a public figure and
this is not just happening to me Pamela
Geller who many of you know who I've
worked with on many occasions she has
had recently several of her YouTube
videos removed and these are not new
ones these are videos going back to 2007
now a 10 year old video that was on
YouTube for 10 years obviously YouTube
didn't think it violated their
guidelines for 10 years and now suddenly
it does because there is this concerted
effort to cut a platform out from under
all of us you may recall also recently
there was the Imam at the Islamic Center
of Riverside California
Omar Shaheen who prayed in front of
video cameras that Allah please destroy
the Jews and annihilate them down to the
last one and that this got a little bit
of notice because the Middle East Media
Research Institute published the video
and I published the video on jihad watch
and not long after that I got a notice
from Twitter because all of the jihad
watch posts go up immediately on Twitter
that's sort of a standard thing and
Twitter notified me that one of my
tweets was being removed for hate speech
and it was the tweet about a Marsha Hien
calling for the annihilation of the Jews
now mind you they weren't upset about a
Marsha Hien they weren't upset that he
had called for the annihilation of the
Jews they were upset that I had reported
upon it
now you might think that that's absurd
but this has been something that's been
going on for years in the Organization
of Islamic Cooperation which is 57
Muslim governments worldwide 56 states
and the Palestinian Authority very
powerful organization the largest voting
bloc at the UN since the collapse of the
Soviet bloc the Organization of Islamic
Cooperation for years has been
publishing regular reports on
Islamophobia and it goes like this if I
mean mom says kill them wherever you
find them then the Organization of
Islamic Cooperation would say well
that's legitimate religious expression
and he has to have his freedom to quote
the Quran because that is three times in
the Quran and if you say anything about
it then you are a hateful bigoted
Islamophobe and then comes along Spencer
or Herot builders or somebody of that
kind and they say look this Imam said
kill them wherever you find them that
goes in the Islamophobia list for the
Organization of Islamic Cooperation it's
not that they don't want these things
propagated they don't want us to know
they're being propagated and that's what
this is all about so Marcia Hien was
fine my reporting on a Marcia Hien got
flagged by Twitter is hate speech now
there is even more for years if you went
to Google and you typed in the word
jihad then my website jihad watch would
be the first to show up and I asked you
to pardon me for so many all this being
so self referential but they are as I am
the one of the people they're trying to
shut down a lot of this is happening to
me so I can't really avoid talking about
personal
incidents in any case for many years
because Google worked on the basis of
the congruence of the subject matter to
the search and the number of and the
popularity of the site because jihad
watch was and is a popular site it would
show up first if you search for jihad
now if you search for jihad now I ask
you to do this but when you do it be
careful because you probably have a
cache and a history and that will skew
your results but if you clear your cache
in your history and then search for
jihad
jehad watch will not show up on even the
first page much less first it will
probably show up on the second page or
after that now why is that there is an
imam in Texas named Omar Suleiman
and Omar Suleiman he recently started to
complain to Google and he said your
Google searches are filled with hate
filled Islamophobia and Google said Oh
will you please help us to cleanse our
Google searches and he said yes I am
very busy but I'd be happy to help and
he did so that now and it's noteworthy
that this was only reported by the
Anadolu agency which is a Turkish news
agency this was not reported by any news
agency in the United States but I found
it at the Anadolu agency that working
with Omar Suleiman Google has now skewed
its search results so that no longer do
you get when you search for anything
regarding Islam Islam jihad Sharia
whatever if you search for a word like
that you don't get the the site that
comes up because it can is in line with
the subject matter of what you're
searching for and is the most popular
site that's no longer how it works the
way it works now is that you only get
material that tells you how Islam is a
religion of peace and if you search for
jihad now the first thing you will get
is a site that says jihad a
misunderstood concept in Islam and if
you click on it it'll tell you all about
how jihad is spiritual struggle and has
nothing to do with terrorism and this
meanwhile of course there are jihad
terrorists who are justifying their
actions by pointing to the Quran and
making recruits among peaceful Muslims
by invoking Islamic teachings but you
will get none of that from your Google
search you won't have not have any idea
why any of that is happening now it was
interesting was that Omar Suleiman
quoted in the Anadolu agency article he
said we don't want Google to censor
legitimate criticism of Islam we only
want Google to censor hate-filled
Islamophobia now
have you ever heard the council on
american-islamic relations or any other
Muslim group in the United States say
hey that's legitimate criticism of Islam
net and they never do that
I myself was dismayed when I published
my first book way back in 2002 and I
thought I was very naive I thought
there's going to be a discussion about
this there's going to be a public debate
about these issues that I've raised
about Islam the book was called Islam
and veiled disturbing questions about
the world's fastest growing faith and
there was nothing instead there were
just charges hate-filled Islamophobia
and I thought wait a minute how can it
be hate-filled Islamophobia I'm saying
these are the passages of the Quran
these are the aspects of Islam that
terrorists are using to make recruits
and to spread their ideology
what's hate-filled it's anything's
hate-filled they are but that was far
too rational they didn't want to have a
rational discussion they wanted to shut
down discussion as the front page
masthead says inside every liberal is a
totalitarian screaming to get out they
wanted to make sure that any and all
criticism of Islam any and all
discussion of how Islam is used by
terrorists all of that would be tarred
as hate-filled Islamophobia that's how
we ended up on the hate group list to
start with and when they say when Omar
Suleiman and the others say we only want
to censor hate filled Islamophobia and
not criticism of Islam the dirty little
secret they're not telling you is is
that any criticism of Islam they
consider and explicitly call hate-filled
Islamophobia and this is a tactic in
line with the Organization of Islamic
Cooperation once again the OIC for years
has been pursuing at the UN initiatives
to compel the United States and the
governments of Western Europe and Canada
as well to criminalize as Martin pointed
out incitement to religious hatred now
incitement to religious hatred besides
being a very elastic term and quite
obviously referring
only to criticism of Islam because
nobody ever gets upset when there's
criticism of Judaism or Christianity it
is also an initiative that's in line
with the blasphemy laws that are encoded
in Sharia Islamic law Islamic law on
penalty of death forbids you to
criticize Allah the Quran Muhammad or
Islam in general on penalty of death and
what is the whole point of terrorism why
were the planes flown into the World
Trade Center and the Pentagon why are
all these terrorist attacks going on in
the first place the whole point of them
is all to weaken and destabilize and
ultimately destroy the governments of
free nations so that the resulting chaos
can be exploited by Islamic groups and
ultimately Islamic law will be
established in the West the whole point
of jihad is to install Sharia and one
other way in which this initiative is
being carried out is by working to make
the West
Impa accept elements of Sharia
voluntarily and now we're doing it under
the guise of hate speech these Sharia
blasphemy laws are being encoded now in
the West and it's not a matter of law
it's a matter of as Hillary Clinton put
it peer pressure and shaming you may
have heard a few weeks ago that Richard
Dawkins was scheduled to speak in
Berkeley and of course he was going to
speak about his atheist writings in his
atheist writings he attacks all
religions and he's very scathing about
Christianity because it's the dominant
religion in the Western world but he
also attacks us long and he was invited
by a leftist group that is very happy
that he attacks religions especially
Christianity but then they cancelled him
and in the cancellation notice they
explained that he was being cancelled
because they had discovered that he
criticized Islam
and that was beyond the pale because
these good leftists have internalized
the idea that criticizing Islam it's
wrong in itself it's if so facto racist
bigoted Islamophobic and hateful no
matter under what circumstances it is
done and no matter by whom it is done
and so they have internalized what the
OIC wants us all to accept that
criticism of Islam is forbidden and this
is a very very far advanced initiative
already you may recall that in San
Bernardino in the December 2nd on
December 2nd 2015 15 people were
murdered by a couple of Islamic jihadis
at a Christmas party and the neighbors
were interviewed right after the attack
you may recall the neighbors of the
attackers scienter is Juan Farook and
tashfeen Malik and the neighbors said
yes you know we saw a lot of suspicious
things we saw people coming and going at
all hours we saw people who had looked
very unsavory we saw all sorts of things
very suspicious going on at this house
did you call the police oh no we didn't
want to get involved in racial profiling
and so 15 people are dead the same thing
happened in Fort Dix a longer ago ten or
twelve years ago now there was a young
man who foiled a jihad plot but when he
found out about it he hesitated and he
he went to a friend and he said I've
seen these very disturbing things should
I go to the police or would that be
racist and the idea that anybody would
even think for a second that it was
racist to oppose an Islamic Jihad
Massacre shows how far advanced this
initiative has already come and now it
is being given teeth as the platforms
are being cut out from under us
did you know that just a couple of
months ago the vice president of
Facebook Joel Kaplan traveled to
Islamabad now that's not really variety
vacation land and he was not vacationing
he was on a mission he met with high
Pakistani government officials
most notably Chaudhry Nisar Ali Khan the
interior minister of Pakistan and he
assured the Pakistani government that
Facebook would remove all material that
was considered blasphemous in Islam this
is this is yet another story that was
not reported in the Western press I
found it in the Pakistani press they
were very happy about it and Chaudhry
Nisar Ali Khan was there saying we
explained to mr. Caplin that the Islamic
religion is the number one thing
important to us and we do not we cannot
stand for seeing it insulted and that
all sounds like maybe you could
understand his point of view until you
realize that counter terror analysis is
considered to be insulting to Islam when
it discusses the motivating ideology
behind the jihad threat and Facebook is
signed on to that and so it was that in
the middle of February at jihad Watch we
used to get four years twenty thousand
referrals a day from Facebook in other
words twenty thousand people a day would
see a jihad watch story in their
Facebook news feeds and click on it and
go to jihad watch and read it twenty
thousand people a day in the middle of
February one day February 11th I believe
it was it dropped to 2000 and has stayed
there it's actually less now it's about
a thousand a day from Facebook you can
still go to Facebook and see the jihad
watch page you can still click on links
but by some algorithms and by removing
it from people's newsfeeds
they have dropped off 90% of the
referrals from facebook did 90 percent
of the people who were reading jihad wat
from Facebook suddenly lose interest and
decide it was a religion of peace
probably not probably they just don't
see it anymore and they don't see it
anymore because Facebook is explicitly
and avowedly
complying with Islamic blasphemy laws at
the behest of the government of Pakistan
it sounds unbelievable I still can't
believe it telling it to you now but I
saw the news story I saw the photos of
Joel Kaplan with Chaudhry Nisar Ali Khan
sitting there in Islamabad
and that coincided with another demand
from the German government the German
government of course Angela Merkel the
Chancellor of Germany was caught on a
hot mic you may recall a couple years
ago demanding to Mark Zuckerberg the
president of Facebook that he removed
hate speech now that coincides perfectly
with the Pakistani government and their
demand to Facebook because by hate
speech Merkel meant criticism of her
disastrous migration policies that are
overwhelming Germany and the rest of
Europe with Muslim migrants who have
been responsible for a massive crime
wave and are destabilizing the societies
of Western Europe that's all hate speech
you can't talk about it and incidentally
when Twitter removed my post about a
Martian they told me that even if they
had decided to stay keep it up it would
probably still not be visible in Germany
because Germany is cracking down very
hard on this they're good at that you
know they have a history of doing this
kind of thing and it's coming back I
think that Angela Merkel will go down in
history as the second most successful
Chancellor of Germany right behind Adolf
Hitler in terms of getting her agenda
across but that agenda is frankly
against freedom now after
charlottesville meanwhile I got a notice
from PayPal because PayPal was also
implementing the Southern Poverty Law
Center hate group lists that jihad watch
could no longer accept donations from
PayPal and after a few days I was
finally able to find another platform
and get jihad watch on to that to get
donations and I got about fifteen
thousand dollars in donations for which
I am very grateful I am only mentioning
to you now however because at the same
time after this charlottesville attack
JP Morgan Chase Apple and MGM Resorts
and James Murdoch Rupert Murdoch's son
all pledged millions of dollars to the
Southern Poverty Law Center millions
and so you know I'm very glad to get
$15,000 and they have millions on the
other side
absolutely millions and I do exhort you
if you have any dealings with any of
those JP Morgan Chase Apple MGM please
withdraw find something else to put your
money in at this point because georgette
pointed out to me before the talk just
now that here you are listening to me
and I'm grateful for your being here and
discussing these issues because they are
absolutely pressing importance but if
you have your money in JP Morgan you are
also financing the effort to silence me
and David and Mark and everybody else
who is fighting this and so the
contradiction ought to be ironed out the
fact is that in the Soviet Union there
was some as that literature you may
recall that it was too dangerous to
print things for the most part and
people would type out stories that
dissented from the Soviet governments
line and would copy them out by hand in
many cases or type out multiple copies
because even to have a carbon was
dangerous and distribute these things
and they were minuscule in their power
minuscule in their distribution and yet
ultimately the Soviet government viewed
them as a very grave threat because they
were telling the truth and the truth was
obvious despite all that this is why
propaganda has to be so repeated all the
time you know we're constantly bombarded
with articles and feature stories and
television shows telling us that Islam
is peace and it's a religion of peace
and it teaches peace why do we keep
having to hear this because it's so
obviously false and we keep having to be
told ignore what you hear don't believe
your lying eyes believe us
propaganda needs constant repetition to
put itself over and so the Soviet
government saw this samizdat literature
is a grave threat even though it was so
small and powerless because it had the
great weapon of truth on its side and
that's what we have in this they're
going to continue to try to close the
platforms on us paypal relented after a
huge outcry
and restored me and Pamela Geller and a
few others who had been dropped but
there were many others I've heard about
like politically incorrect in Germany
and several other sites that have been
dropped from PayPal and they have not
been restored and have no recourse
because they don't have the platforms
that we have to Marshall opinion I urge
you to be aware of this to lend all
support that you possibly can to people
that are fighting this but also never to
lose hope to continue to speak the truth
and to stand for the truth and know that
the Soviet government in its great
anxiety over the semijns debt literature
reveals the weakness at the heart of
totalitarianism and totalitarianism is
on the march and trying to advance in
the US but as David pointed out they
always overreach and they're
overreaching now and so we still have a
chance to preserve freedom and to
preserve a society in which the freedom
of speech is respected but that calls on
every one of us to become an activist
and to fight in whatever sphere that we
can to preserve this the greatest
society in the history of the world and
thank you very much for being here with
all these treasonous corporations and
search engines and everything else or is
there any discussion of creating new
search engines and websites that would
take the place of the PayPal's and the
Facebook's because we're just getting
slaughtered there is there is discussion
of creating new platforms and that's
something that I hope proceeds you would
need people of immense wealth to be able
to give them enough reach to be able to
stand up and compete these companies are
essentially monopolies and not only that
but they're essentially judgment-proof
because there is a thing called the
Communications Decency Act that Barack
Obama shepherded through while he was
president and section 230 of the
Communications Decency Act actually
protects the social media platforms from
legal challenge so they can act as
monopolies and they can destroy
freedom of speech and deny it to people
who don't follow the leftist line and
there's nothing we can do we can't sue
them so there is actually a lawsuit
proceeding and on the participants in it
to challenge that section 230 and to
challenge the US government but it's a
very strange thing because we didn't sue
Facebook we sued the government and the
government said you're suing the wrong
guy you should have sued Facebook and so
it's a big legal game you know how
lawyers are and that is still proceeding
but but rather than litigating against
them just compete against them great yes
I'm all for it there are efforts there's
a thing called gap which is competing
with Twitter but it's much smaller
they need they need massive financing
there's no alternative Facebook that I
know of but ultimately I think the only
thing we can do is try to work toward
breaking the power of these in these
groups and that's something that I hope
that will be done first I'd like to
point people to an article that I
published oh maybe a year and a half ago
on American Thinker called why I love
hate speech that was a an article in
support of Pamela Geller and the fact
that they have a fight on her and
they're trying to behead her but what I
wanted to say Robert is that that I had
the insight I had when you were telling
us about Joel Kaplan was that what we
need to take from the Joel Kaplan
anecdote anecdote is that he is terras
terrorize the whole point is that they
have succeeded and what they have done
is they have literally terrorized people
and Joel Kaplan is actually afraid that
if he doesn't go there to Pakistan I
have the meeting with this man that he
will be beheaded that's very likely yes
this is the problem I think don't you
agree with me and maybe you could say
some words about this that our approach
needs to be now instead of attacking
these people who are attacking us to
attack the whole concept of being
terrorized and how we simply cannot
allow ourselves to be terrorized well
you know that's that's very true and
very important
unfortunately it's going the other
direction I have to note for example in
the book the complete infidels guide to
free speech in its enemies I have a
chapter called from Rushdie to Gellar
and it's about how in 1989 when Salman
Rushdie got his death fatwa from the
Islamic Republic of Iran for writing The
Satanic Verses he was celebrated as a
hero and there was all sorts of material
in the Western press about how the
freedom of speech was important and that
Rushdie was somebody who had to be stood
with and defended now fast-forward that
26 years later to 2015 and when pamela
geller put on and i aided her in putting
on the muhammad art exhibit and cartoon
contest in Garland Texas that was
attacked by terrorists we were she was
absolutely excoriated not only on the
left but by people on Fox people who
were conservatives Bill O'Reilly and
Laura Ingraham and Donald Trump
criticized her and said you know what
are you doing drawing Mohammed you
should know better you have to show
respect and nobody seemed to understand
anymore the principles of free speech
that everybody took for granted and
understood in 1989 and that the idea
that you don't give into violent
bullying violent intimidation but you
stand up to the bully something that we
all learned in fifth grade everybody is
forgotten and everybody takes for
granted now it seems to me or far too
many people even among so-called
conservatives take for granted the idea
that if somebody is bullying you you
just give him what he wants
you if they're telling you will kill you
if you draw Mohammed then you must not
draw Mohammed and they don't recognize
the implications of this for the freedom
of speech and for a free society saying
yeah I think that in great degree Malory
that's because we have been terrorized
and that terrorism keeps happening
because it works and that we need to
recognize that and grow some regain some
spine
yeah hi conservatives have a natural
aversion to politics because it's so
ugly and you have to step on principles
all the time and make pacts with the
devil however I'm sorry I say
conservatives have a natural aversion to
politics and I'm here as a former
radical huh to say look we won the last
election there is now a Trump party
within the Republican Party the way to
deal with this it seems to me I mean I
just occurred to me while listening to
you
we have antitrust laws break up fright
Facebook break up Google we also there's
talk about converting them into treating
them as public utilities which they are
so the for us our power now is in the
political realm all these other things
we can do but that Google is it's the
biggest corporation in the history of
the world you can't you can't fight them
by forming your own little little things
it's a monopoly and we have as I say
antitrust laws so I would say those of
you were involved in Republican Party
politics find the relevant committees
find the relevant there's got to be
somewhere in the Congress a good person
you know talk to the freedom caucus put
this on the agenda that's the way to
fight them I will tell you if we just
and we will do this a front page create
a drumbeat prayer invoking antitrust
laws and you have the you know you
probably to write the article because
you're at all that evidence that you
proposed that will scare the bejesus out
of Zuckerberg and and and the executives
they are I think more they fear more
than being beheaded they fear losing
money in the whole muscle
world that's not that's what that's
about it's political look at the the
best thing that's happened to the right
since I've been part of it it started
with the Tea Party is that conservatives
who despise politics and think that
politics only takes place every four
years or every two years for Congress
the Conservatives are finally there
marching they're organizing and this has
grown dramatically when we talk even
about universities I mean there are now
large conservative student movements
when I came into the right there was no
conservatives to I you know it's the
first thing I looked over where the
troops where's that ground war where is
the armies and actually one of the
really good campus organizations young
America's Foundation their board of
directors didn't know I I said why why
you have representatives on a thousand
campuses where are your chapters a our
board won't let us form chapters well
that's changed charlie Kirk has an
organization with Johnny I think he has
like a thousand colleges things are
really changing but they're changing in
the political realm and it requires I
know a big internal shift for
conservatives to get you know dirty in
that political just jump in and start
fighting that's where we can win as I
was saying at lunch we have there are
three very important Senate races one in
Alabama one in Nevada and one in Arizona
and the anti-trump Republicans the Pro
McConnell Republicans are losing in all
three in Jeff Flake who wrote this
preposterous book attacking his own
president is losing by forty seven to
twenty
and that's even before Joe our pail gets
into the race thank you yeah you know I
think it's very very important if we
could make antitrust legislation
targeting Google Facebook Twitter all of
them in 2018 and 2020 leftist microphone
Robert I just wondered if you could
address the silencing of free speech
Donald Trump's free speech by people
like McMaster where he's not allowed to
say radical Islam anymore so and can you
turn to him or anyone in the
administration anymore for help with
this or is john bolton said the other
day the doors are closed it doesn't it's
very curious because of course Donald
Trump appointed all these people and I
don't really know I don't have his ear I
don't know why he appointed them but it
does seem as if everyone except for
Steve Miller who of course is formerly
with the David Horowitz Freedom Center
he is the only one left that I know of
who is aware of what's really important
about that issue of course Donald Trump
campaigned for president rebuking Barack
Obama and Hillary Clinton for not daring
to say radical Islamic terrorism when I
saw that I thought he meant he was going
to restore study of the motivating
ideology of jihad terrorists to
government and law enforcement you may
find this hard to believe but in 2011
Barack Obama ordered all counter terror
training materials scrubbed of any
reference to Islam so that ever since
then up till now
if you were to join the FBI today and
you say I want to go into counter terror
you'll learn all about right-wing
extremists and constitutionalists and
militiamen and so on and white
supremacists and neo-nazis but you won't
hear a thing about Islamic Jihad ease
and you won't know anything about them
you have to know your enemy to defeat
him and we do not know the enemy it's a
matter of policy that we do not know the
enemy so I thought Trump was going to
change that but then he appointed people
who have the Obama point of view on this
that you cannot name Islam in connection
with terrorism because it will get the
Muslims on our side angry and embolden
the jihadis this is preposterous because
the Muslims if they're really on our
side know full well where the terrorism
is coming from and if they're really on
our side should not have any problem
with fighting it but in any case that is
the dominant view among the National
Security Adviser HR McMaster and many
others in the Trump administration and
he did prescind from saying Islamic
terrorism for the very first time in his
speech about Afghanistan several weeks
ago prompting the resignation of one of
the last people who was speaking about
this with any remote degree of honesty
Sebastian Gorka who specifically
referred to Trump's failure to address
this regarding Afghanistan as the reason
for his resignation
so it's a very strange situation what's
going on with the White House it seems
as if everybody who was in favor of the
agenda the president campaigned upon is
gone and people who were actively
against it are in positions of power but
at the same time whenever we get really
distressed about this just step back and
think about what it would be like now if
Hillary Clinton were president and
consider the fact that we're even
speaking about this issue instead of
just taking for granted that we are
going to continue to ignore what the
enemy is all about and that we're even
speaking about restricting illegal
immigration and restricting North Korea
from its adventurism and all these
things that wouldn't even be on the
table where Hillary Clinton president so
things aren't as bad as they might seem
in microcosm and we can also hope that
the president who is always displayed
good instincts in understanding these
issues will recover some sense of what
he was elected for and continue to
pursue it and he doesn't really need
people around him to do that he just
needs himself and Twitter
[Music]
thank thank you so much Robert thank you